la minute de vérité et ce sera pas une
seconde de plus depuis son élection le
15 décembre dernier
weidmann à la brasse plus belle et elle
est magnifique et son prénom ça j'aime
bien je riais les toits ne cesse de
faire parler d'elle la jeune femme
n'hésite pas à répondre à ses
détracteurs
quitte à faire le buzz moi c'est ce qui
me plaît chez elle voit la dernière
polémique en date elle est accusé de se
moquer des handicapés après avoir publié
une photo assise sur un monte-escalier
cherche-t-elle à faire le buzz ou encore
une fois est-ce que c'est un buzz
voilà qui sait on a beaucoup parlé de ça
pour rien dites nous la vérité qui
touchent que vous en pensez vidéo rappel
des faits comprenez vous les critiques
sur ce qui s'est passé
vous nous dites oui ou non c'est parti
le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
qu'en seulement quelques mois vaima lama
chaves a réussi à se faire un nom grande
gagnante de l'édition 2019 du concours
miss france va y comme beaucoup la
surnomme a été couronnée reine de beauté
mais méritent également le titre de
reine du buzz la première fois qu'elle a
fait parler d'elle c'est lors de son
apparition dans l'émission on n'est pas
couché sur france 2 la jeune femme a été
victime d'une blague jugée sexiste de
laurent ruquier une réflexion qui a
beaucoup fait réagir les internautes
vous qui nous regardent et en ce moment
dans votre lit pour relancer la natalité
nous avons invité ce soir notre miss
france ça devrait vous donner des idées
voilà c'est face à un autre laurent
qu'elle s'est ensuite fait remarquer un
beatty de thierry ardisson sur ces huit
la miss n'a pas hésité à promettre à sa
place avec humour laurent baffie et
c'est sur instagram cette fois ci que la
miss a fait parler d'elle avec une
publication qui a été jugé par certains
comme une moquerie envers les personnes
en situation de handicap
lentement mais sûrement je fais les
choses à mon rythme mais j'avoue avoir
été particulièrement à l'entrée de front
une miss qui n'hésite pas à dire ce
qu'elle pense ça ne plaît pas à tout le
monde à l'intérieur même du cercle très
fermé des miss rachel trapani miss
france 2007 a déclaré à son sujet pacal
m'énerve c'est juste que moi j'ai été un
peu à l'ancienne école moi j'étais super
impressionné par par geneviève etc
j'osais pas me la ramener comme ça alors
mr oms accusée de vouloir faire le buzz
comprenez vous ces critiques
alors comprenez vous ces critiques on va
avec le chrono derrière moi y'en a plein
alors vous comprenez pas beaucoup si
kelly tiens j'ai envie d'avoir votre
avis là-dessus alors moi je trouve que
non je ne comprends pas du tout les
critiques par rapport à elle elle a un
caractère trempé elle on voit que c'est
là un parcours particulier on voit que
c'est une femme qui a eu une faire face
à des difficultés dans sa vie estimé
qu'elle ne se laisse pas faire je
redoute qu'on n'est pas à la dernière
comment dirais-je vannes on va dire et
au buzz de vaillière lama ça ce sont et
ne se laisse pas faire toujours par
lesquels va toujours dire ce qu'elle
pense et que voilà derrière son sourire
5 est une vraie grande personnalité se
sont tues tu as tu paye des impôts payés
oui vous vous êtes choqués oui moi je
suis choquée parce qu'effectivement
d'abord ne cherche qu'à faire que du
buzz je suis choqué quand elle dit entre
les mots comme se branler à l'antenne et
tout ça comme elle l'a fait dans des
tweets
elle est élue pour être belle elle n'est
pas marianne ne représenteraient
d'autres jeux des nations lui n'est pas
terminée ce qu'on lui demande c'est
prendre sa 508 de faire la quinzaine du
reblochon des jo
je trouve qu'elle ne cherche qu'à faire
du buzz pour exister derrière et devenir
chroniqueuse et où je sais pas ou alors
vous feront vous dire un truc vous avez
pris 20 piges mais ce rigoler à broadway
depuis trois depuis trois semaines un
vrai il n'ya que des idées là comme la
dernière fois je suis désolé sur le
jeune garçon qui sait manier aussi des
trucs enfin ça vous choque pas voulu que
ce soit pour ce bras était nous avait
110 ans à l'examen non mais je trouve
pas du tout innocent ça moi ça me lasse
parce qu'effectivement pour une fois
elle dit les choses simplement
elle s'exprime pourquoi ça vous dérange
d'une femme est pourquoi le comment tu
peux dire aujourd'hui
abba est là pour être belle ces
dégradations
allez on a été élu l'élection est
terminée
arrête de dire qu'une nana allait elle
est là pour être belle et pour aller à
l'aventuré du pourquoi certains mais tu
te rends compte que tu dis on avait eu
concret dans l'histoire comme un
accessoire de beauté c'est une belle et
sans les sags nom et elle est vendue
roblochon stupide s'est dégradée
craindre en présence et de faire ce
contenu géraldine la pression avant la
vie de delphine bien sûr la très moderne
être aussi intelligent je recalé dans
l'air du temps que pour le pour une fois
les poussières la langue de bois à miss
france qui est juste insupportable 20 et
elle et moi je trouve absolument
parfaite alors delfini question penses
quoi toi tu t'es mis du côté de ceux qui
comprennent les critiques envers me
plaît c'est à dire jeu oui elle fait du
buzz
oui elle fait du buzz mais je pense que
c'est un peu malgré elle et je pense
qu'elle a une personnalité sans filtre
ça il ya eu plusieurs tournants dans
miss france sophie thalmann c'était le
tournant des miss qui vont à la télé
elle c'est le tournant des miss aux noms
qui osent l'ouvrir qui osent juste ne
pas sourire quand un politique lui met
la main aux fesses qui osent répondent
quand un présentateur nous l'organisons
mal géré ou sociaux je conviens les
crimes n'ont jamais cessé malgré elle
c'est s'appelle malgré un jugement elle
ose l'ouvrir
il nous a fait une réponse jean oui bah
moi je comprends pas parce qu'enfin je
trouve ça un peu maladroit de sa part
pour te rejoindre c'est un peu malgré
elle je pense ce buzz mais moi qui fais
partie de la génération un peu 2.0
sociaux tout ça fait du bien un peu
d'avoir eu ma joie aujourd'hui je tape
les gens me wade je suis aux clientèles
qu'est ce qu'elle veut c'est pas malgré
elle elle est hyper intelligente et
c'est ce qu'elle fait et à la raison
dans le monde on vit actuellement il
faut faire du buzz il faut se montrer et
pourquoi pas après le présentera je ne
sais quoi elle si elle peut avoir dit
d'accord ne cherche que le buzz mais
elle ne cherche pas un gros elle est
juste intelligente jamais de fumée sans
feu évidemment si les routes tant de
polémiques sur une aussi de courte durée
depuis son élection c'est bien parce
qu'elle crée celle créée ce genre
d'ambiance et je suis désolé c'est pas
une ambassadrice de la france s'est
jusqu'à maintenant une marque
commerciale
absolument et bien alors et vite
je suis partagé je suis partagé ex que
di maria lund c'est vrai que ce serait
intéressant pied d un peu de punch et de
répartie et tout mais sur le sur les
handicapés non merci au dessus des
séries télé séries6 terminé s'il vous
plaît terminé on regarde pensez vous que
miss france 2010 de recherche à faire le
buzz
oui trente ans nous à 60% c'est terminé